so plan b for many of you that don't
know is a pseudonymous person uh that is
on twitter and became very well known as
he continued to post the stock to flow
model for bitcoin and that stock to flow
model there was a bunch of debate much
controversy but so far has proven to be
deadly accurate some may say lethal in
the accuracy of that stock to flow model
and so
every once in a while we like to check
in just see how is it going what do we
see in that model we've got a whole
bunch of tweets and charts here from
plan b
twitter handle is at 100 trillion usd
you read into that however you want
zimbabwe 100 trillion dollar bill usd
we'll see bitcoin stock to flow model
again the reason why this is so lethal
is the supply of bitcoin is known with
certainty we know that the bitcoin that
comes in on a daily basis into the
circulating supply is 900 bitcoin per
day we also know exactly how many blocks
it will take in order to get to the next
having cycle on top of that we obviously
have the price the past price movements
and so we can use that to extrapolate
out what the future demand of bitcoin is
likely to be and so you can see here the
white line is essentially the um you
know uh proposed movements of bitcoin uh
what the model shows and then obviously
the colored lines end up being what the
actual price has been it is lethal now
if we move to something that's a little
bit more smoothed out we can see that
there's a chart that shows the bitcoin
200 day weekly moving average and then
also realized cap and so if we blow this
up a little bit you can see the red line
ends up being that or i'm sorry the
black line ends up being the 200-day
weekly moving average the gray line ends
up being the realized cap and then
obviously the colored lines end up being
the price so why is this important it
shows that regardless of how you measure
bitcoin whether it is the realized cap
meaning how much money has gone into
bitcoin that is up if you look at the
200-day weekly moving average that is up
as well and then if you obviously look
at price that is up as well and so all
three of these metrics continue to show
price appreciation that is very very
very bullish barring some sort of
external catastrophic event bitcoin
looks like it is being repriced in the
world as a global store of value and the
world is trying to figure out what is
this asset worth we then move to the
worst case scenario 2021 of the bitcoin
stock to flow model again coming from
plan b here what you can see is that the
worst case scenarios end up still being
very bullish now the reason why these
charts are so fascinating to me
personally is because when you look at
bitcoin as an asset people are still
pricing it in u.s dollar terms and so
there is no other asset that i am aware
of on the planet that allows you to see
this far into the future and have such
lethal accuracy to the future price
movements and again it comes back to
that idea of certainty if you are a
digital native and you have grown up on
the internet you are used to hearing
things in the media and saying i don't
know if that's true or not let me go
research and you actually go and try to
verify it yourself there's also a lot of
information that in the financial
markets people may say something whether
it's a narrative or try to uh make an
argument and you can go and you can
actually research it yourself that is
the beauty of bitcoin is it's don't
trust verify what you're able to do is
you're able to go run a node yourself
you can verify on a blockchain exactly
how many bitcoin there are total how
many are in circulation how many are
coming in on a daily basis and we can
see all of those on-chain metrics the
on-chain metrics do not lie you can see
exactly who's buying who's selling how
long have they been holding what's their
historical behavior look like what is
the current price movement and what do
we expect to happen in the future to
demand based on that programmatic
monetary policy i personally believe
what we are watching is one of the most
important technologies in the world get
re-priced by the world because the
programmatic monetary policy is 180
degree difference than any other
currency in the world remember in
technology investing
if you want outsized returns what do you
have to do you have to do something
different and be right if you simply do
what everyone else is doing you're going
to get the same return that everyone
else is getting so what you can do is
you can invest in something that is
different and you're right it appears
that bitcoin is structurally 180 degree
different than any of the fiat
currencies and so if it ends up being
successful which so far it appears that
it will could change but so far all on
track then it is likely to produce the
outsized returns over the last decades
the best performing asset in the entire
financial market no guarantee that that
will happen in the future but it
definitely looks like plan b
with the stock to flow model has one of
if not the most accurate
price model for bitcoin moving forward
what do you guys think about this i like
plan b
is a legend um
exactly what you said right we know the
schedule of supply so you have to look
at the demand side uh and plan b has
developed a model here the stock to flow
model that has accurately predicted in
the past and looks to be doing so at a
at a good pace going into the future um
so he he doesn't sway from his uh his
predictions on twitter and stuff like
that he's been extremely accurate uh and
it looks like again not financial advice
but uh you might want to buckle up looks
like we might be going for a ride here
soon
john yeah i can't agree more um
i like how he has predicted in the past
he hasn't swayed from what he said um
and one thing this makes you think about
is just all these student anonymous
accounts that are popping up right some
of them are really knowledgeable and
people are hiding their identities for
multiple different reasons right even
the creator of bitcoin satoshi him
herself what whatever they are um
it's cool to see that like some people
don't care about fame in the sense and
maybe one day plan b will reveal
themselves as uh who they are but it's
it's nice to see there's still some good
people doing some good work work in the
world
one of the other pieces i think about
this analysis if we pull up the chart
and look at it is um those
charts actually were not created for
bitcoin right this is a historical
finance model meaning the stock to flow
usually around gold or other types of
precious metals ended up being uh
believed or adopted by financial
investors now when you take it and you
apply it to this new bitcoin uh asset
all of a sudden there's people who say
oh stop the flow doesn't work right oh
that's going to be violated et cetera
we'll see but it is fascinating to me
that this specific model it's not a
bitcoin exclusive model right so you're
taking an old model and applying it here
and i think part of the debate that
we've seen around bitcoin is if you're a
traditional value investor and you say
hey uh what is the discounted cash flows
right what is the uh earnings per share
uh what is the revenue multiple and you
start to look at some of this stuff you
struggle to understand exactly how to
value this how to uh identify is it
undervalued or overvalued right now what
is the future price movements of it look
like how do i think about supply and
demand et cetera but when you do use the
stock to flow model it appears that is
the most accurate and so in some way uh
the skeptics the critics the people who
don't necessarily believe in bitcoin it
may be simply because they're using it
the incorrect framework or a less
superior framework to the stock to flow
and if you simply look at the stock to
flow and you say hey this model is the
accurate model which again is up for
debate uh then all of a sudden it
becomes very clear and you tend to be
much more bullish on bitcoin end of year
worst case scenario 100k plan b set it
not me
yeah i think that's a good point though
is like for traditional economists and
people that operated in the markets and
have invested for a long time it's a
completely different asset class right
so you have to look at it from a
different standpoint you have to remove
yourself from the traditional models
that you would uh typically evaluate a
stock or a bond or real estate or some
other asset in and you have to zoom out
and you have to be able to do it from a
different lens and i think stock to flow
model is obviously one of those there's
other things that are uh relevant in the
on-chain metrics that develop a good use
case but i think the people that have
been able to do the best have been able
to remove themselves from the
traditional way of thinking outside of
stocks bonds uh and everything else
within the traditional assets asset set
and looked at it from a different lens
for crypto and i think you're gonna have
to continue to do that because if you
look at it from the other lenses it
doesn't make much sense right it doesn't
produce cash flow it doesn't have all
these other uh these other qualities
that you would look for in a traditional
asset so the people that have uh changed
their thinking and gone into crypto and
done the work and all that kind of stuff
have realized that and the other people
that are still
not seeing it as a viable ass and all
these other things have yet to do that
it seems plan b on june 20th tweeted a
couple of numbers and what he said was
my worst case scenario for 2021 based on
price and on-chain uh behavior was
august 47k at the close
check
squeaked it in yesterday squeaked right
in there 47k got it september 43k
down a little bit worst case scenario
october 63k november 98k december worst
case scenario according to plan b 135
000 bitcoin price so what we're watching
say the lawyer part
terms and conditions go read them
august worst case scenario from plan b
was 47k september 43k october 63k
november 98 december 135 000. worst case
is a pretty strong statement to be
talking about worst case scenario by
december uh of 2021 being 135 000
obviously with the idea that if that's
the worst case it's somewhere above that
why do you think it's a dip in september
that he's predicting or on a worst case
scenario
look when these assets move they move up
very very violently remember we went
from 64 to 30 over you know what two
months or so three almost three months
and one day it went like 43 44 45 and
like a three hour span
you were excited huh
you liked that i liked that day
so the idea is uh when you get these
violent moves upwards somebody somewhere
is gonna take profits and so when they
do that that obviously puts cell
pressure on the market it's going to
drop down it's going to get some relief
to it it'll kind of consolidate and then
it'll move up again um and so if you
look all the way back to october
november of 2020 it's at 10k 11k 12k
right whatever it was in there then we
went from that to 30 by the end of the
year then from 30 to 64 back down to 30.
now we're sitting around 45 47 you know
somewhere in that range and then the
idea is that we'd move back up again get
some relief consolidate et cetera this
is a normal market you see this in all
markets it's not bitcoin specific it
just happens to be that the numbers the
percentages are much uh kind of wilder
than you would get in a nutritional
market but as we've even seen with the
meme stocks traditional stocks even um
you know kind of the mega cap um you
know blue chip stocks when they move up
violently whatever that is on that
percentage basis what you find is that
there has to be some profit taking
people can't stay forever uh without
without taking profits and there's those
numbers right there so by the end of
december 2021 plan b worst case scenario
ends up being 135k we'll see could be
wrong who knows but pretty bullish uh
coming from the creator of the bitcoin
stock to flow model what's up guys bang
bang thanks so much for watching the
best business show today if we're gonna
be the best business show we obviously
need the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]